[Musique]
sixième jour de ce festival de cannes
tu es là pour la soutenir gilles
lellouche qui présente ce soir nous
embarquons technique très très envie de
voir ce film je devrais pas le dire mais
c'est vraiment quasiment le seul film
que j'ai pu y voir c'est celui-là ne
faut pas le dire parce que ça c'est pas
propre à le gardeur le dira voilà sans
douleur livraisons sont en dur avec jean
paul rouve jean paul rouve qui signent
des autographes qui paie des photos bon
cela que j'en parle
comment ça se passe a très bien les gens
adorables de suite depuis les tuche est
ce que vous pouvez sortir dans la rue
tranquille un peu moins c'est vrai un
peu moins un peu voire pas oui mais bon
ouais enfin s'en plaindra le succès du
film ses démons voulait pas que nos co
animateurs du festival de cannes a
laissé aller could place mais n'a alors
on est venu voir le film des copains ce
soir là exactement le film de gilles
lellouche parce que
et la natation synchronisée exactement
on est double champion olympique chacun
et puis pour ma part je viens de tourner
un film avec gilles qui s'appelle grand
paris le nouveau film de mohamed hamidi
et on est venu soutenir les copains et
croque l'équipe du grand arrivent à pied
apparemment oui il arrive à pied sur le
problème
elle est belle elle est belle cette
image et ça c'est vraiment c'est ce très
beau
les images j'ai deux louches tonkin et
alice pu tuer jussieu je suis mort de
trac mais je suis fou johnny depp rikers
toute ma famille du cinéma organisée
gilles énormément de personnalités ce
soir et ce niveau c'est qu'à chaque fois
qu'on leur demande vous faites quoi tout
le monde nous dit on est venu soutenir
les copains sert qu'on sent qu'il ya
quand même une inventé un amour pour
vous pour ce film est pour tout votre
casting est quand même dingue
abbas à mort en fou du roi et vous me
l'apprenez donc ça me ravit encore plus
on vous a vu tout cet après midi au
photocall ya eu c'est un moment oui
aussi way extra au delà sabit geci
d'abondance et senna vont chanter ces
suppléments chez leurs en bas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]